but like a big thing that i've kind of
like felt recently is that
like i've kind of like thought what is
the direction that gaming is going to go
right what because i've uh i've recently
procured myself a playstation 5. i know
guys
yeah the lucky few and the reason i did
that was entirely because i was like i'm
not gonna i don't need a ps5 yet i don't
need a ps5 and then
horizon forbidden west came out and
horizon zero dawn was like one of my
favorite games of all time so i'm like
all right this kind of deserved the
special treatment i'll try and go out my
way to get a ps5 in order to play this
game yeah and
the game looks [ __ ] amazing it looks
[ __ ] fantastic right um but is it
is it that different from playing it on
a ps4 i wouldn't really say so you know
i i i i feel like
hyper realism in video games has almost
reached the limit to the point where
it's like yeah we can't get any better
graphics don't look that much different
yeah yeah um like eight years ago yeah
they don't they they can't get any
better than this like i remember jumping
from like i remember the first time i
got my n64 and i played super mario 64.
and like my mind [ __ ] blue it was
like i was like like running around in
3d
after after 2d mario or all this time
like i could not comprehend yeah i was
such an expert
and now i'm just like i think there are
extra pixels that i'm that my eye is
seeing right now right i feel like you
have
i feel like it's a bit smoother because
there are slightly more frames but it
certainly it suddenly isn't like the
mind-blown kind of experience that i
felt before but that's what i'm saying
like that that's why i feel like we've
almost reached that limit when it comes
to like amazing graphically how games
can be and that's why i feel like
especially the indie scene for the past
like 10 years has been more focused on
making these more like stylized games
like pixel games and stuff like that
like you know what i want back i want
cell shading in games back can we can we
have that back has it ever left
i think it's like it used to be in the
forefront i feel of like all the main
line games or like the movies
in a way i think so i think for like
certain demographics like you know like
when like wind waker came out for
example everyone [ __ ] hated it at
first until they played and they
realized how amazing it was yeah i i
remember when everyone when wind waker
came out and there was so much
discussions in like magazines to be like
this is a step down
like this is a graphical step now that's
what the trend was right it was realism
really doesn't mean yeah yeah it wasn't
real and then and then when we started
getting used to the cell shader [ __ ]
like with um what's it uh lollipop
chainsaw is like another game series
that's like very cell shaded very
stylized right yeah people were also
like oh man this game looks
too [ __ ] weird like it's it's it's
not pretty enough and then people
immediately when they played the game
they found out oh you know what this is
pretty but just on a different caliber
of pretty yeah i mean like i would say
like wind waker has aged the best
visually in terms like i i i would argue
like pretty much every zelda game yeah
you know i mean i i think it looks
better than pokemon
and the best thing yeah exactly and the
best thing is those kinds of styles a
lot of the times are ageless yeah like
like a cuphead yeah oh yeah exactly or
like you know like wind waker looks just
as good in even in today's standards
because it's so stylized whereas if you
go back to like you know uh ocarina of
time
right you're like you're like oh
not as pretty as my 12 year old my
background i thought it was a fugly game
yeah it's not a pretty so if you have
the context you know the setting and
stuff it makes sense of course you know
people who say like you know with all
those n64 games who are like no no looks
it looks just as good today or obviously
they're just operating off nostalgia
yeah right but like anyone can look at
mario 64 and go
[ __ ] me that's an ugly game yeah you
know yeah it just i just think maurice's
foot looks kind of good
you think compared to like ocarina well
yeah like if you look at something like
golden eye golden eye looks
awful oh that looks beautiful
and you know and ocarina of time i think
it looks awful i don't know mario 64
like i i don't know why i think it looks
okay
don't get aged as bad as
you might think i think you you should
probably take like a closer look i have
i have cause i i was
it looks like [ __ ] okay i'll give you
that bowser looks like [ __ ] the peach in
the opening scene i'm just like ah
what is that that is true actually
because when when i think of mario 64
for some reason i go to mario sunshine
yeah because that was like i guess my my
childhood marriage yeah yeah i remember
and mary's sunshine has aged a lot
better uh visually visually than mario
64. yeah
yeah because uh with yeah i feel like
that generation of games like um like
i wouldn't say ps1 because like i look
back at like metal gear solid one and i
i look back at like pixels talking to
each other like
snake's face does he doesn't have detail
it's like it's just like one triangle
it's just a triangle and i remember
thinking how the [ __ ] did i get invested
in these cut scenes of the snake going
aricon and it's just like a pixel going
you know but like i i feel like the ps2
gamecube era was kind of when we started
really
like really getting to
getting to the point where i couldn't
see that much of a big jump in graphical
fidelity yeah yeah and then afterwards i
i did see a difference with ps3
ps3 to me is when it kind of like peaked
you know where you know
what last of us originally came out on
the ps3 right and i was just like i to
me like the original last of us
like pretty much every game looks about
the same as last year yes you know even
though i could tell they look
graphically better they're not that much
graphically better that i think my god
this is a [ __ ] mind-blowing amount of
improvement yeah but he looks pretty bad
though
that's because the wii had like very
limited hearts where are we in um isn't
it 480p the wii yeah i think so it has a
native resolution of 40. yeah and it's
just upscale yeah it looks rough when
you go back and play it you're like oh
cause i remember as a kid when super
smash brothers melee no uh brawl came
out yeah i remember i thought dude this
is like the pinnacle
i thought i thought that was a twilight
princess yeah insane yeah and then i
looked back like a like a year ago and i
was like what the [ __ ] it looked like
that the entire time
because i'm i'm remembering the rendered
cut scenes for that game yeah the cut
scenes look amazing yeah because we're
coming because of course they [ __ ] yeah
but i think in with in the case with
that generation of consoles like the wii
i think it depends on the game as well
because like twilight princess still
looks great even though that's a wii
game i think it still looks great i
haven't liked it but
think every single footage i've seen
princess of late has been the uh hd
remake hd but if you look at it
comparatively like a lot of these like
hd remasters
i don't really see the point of calling
them hd remasters because if you put
them side by side they're really unless
you're like a [ __ ] you know pixel
snob like you're not gonna see it like
you know when uh final fantasy 10
remaster came out right like the hd
remaster yeah i played it and i was like
how does this look any different to the
ps2 version also did did you see the uh
the gta
uh three remastered no that was a
disaster oh really it was like the game
load worse
did you all see this i didn't see this
it was like a massive controversy no i
didn't say this at all they like took
off the original grand theft auto and
you couldn't buy it right the original
third one yeah and they're like you have
to buy the remake they they reversed it
a little bit i can't remember exactly
what they did yeah but they released
this remake and it looked worse than the
original
it was like they just turned like the
smoothness option on like everything had
just been smooth right right the people
just looked even weirder in the
cutscenes
and all of it looked have you not seen
the um okay let me quickly grab a few
images and show you i'm going to type in
uh grandpa auto
gta 3 remastered uh
images images
uh comparison
comparison okay
yeah so like look at this
this is the original and this is the
remastered
oh oh
that's gross that's just uncanny yeah
there's also yeah um there's so many
where like it doesn't look
like that much better yeah yeah it's
like i i i'd say the original has more
character to it yeah yeah a lot of the
cutscenes the characters just look worse
yeah it's really weird i just don't
understand but that's the thing with
like again that's the thing with like hd
remasters right like when they did they
see remastered wind waker i was like
this legitimately looks no different it
still looks just as good it does look a
bit crisper
though i think it's very minute though i
would say right like like you know
compared to like final fantasy 7 and
final fantasy vii remake like you know
yeah exactly like you know that's that's
a big that's a big job yeah it's like
jumping it's a difference between a
remake and a rematch right right true
well yeah they just kind of like
upped the contrast and smoothed it all
out and made it probably just higher
yeah yeah higher higher resolution but
like it's like
it's so stylized yeah that like in terms
of like actual graphical updates or
upgrades it's like it's not something to
write home about yeah if you look at the
images it just looks like the edges are
smoother yeah like rtx has been turned
on well you're not you're not going to
see that big of a difference when you're
playing the game it wouldn't make a
difference
play in the game not at all yeah i mean
i i guess that's talking about like the
graphical differences as well but in
terms like gameplay differences i feel
like the gaming industry as a whole has
just like optimized pretty much like 90
of everything they can that can be
optimized and you know every so often we
get something like uh breath of the wild
that completely changes the way you look
at like an open world for example and
now every open world game has a glider
for some reason even if it doesn't need
it
i feel like the technology is
less so focused on
making the things very uh high graphics
or making the textures more advanced
it's like i think right now a lot of the
technology from what i understand is
focused on like um like the the lighting
and stuff right so yeah making it so
when you put a character in a world that
you can add all of the effects naturally
so instead of having a beam of light and
you programming like the light is here
it's like
you program the room and then you have a
bunch of options to like turn on the
i've got the name of the lighting thing
is it's like it's like lighting where it
uses like the calculations like figure
out what would happen if like a ball
went in the way yeah reflection stuff i
think that's where a lot of the the
advancements are being made not so much
in like the individual
um like assets makeup because yeah the
models that we have of characters in
games are very very high quality oh they
are and they have been for a while yeah
the only thing that's left is making how
the models interact with the world more
realistic if they want that or you know
whatever they want to do and so now it's
about making the machines that can do
these animations or do these things
built in and do them smoother from what
i understand i could be totally wrong
some of my correctness that's that's
what i want to know right it's like
what's the once we've perfected that
hypothetically what's the next step well
that's why i do look to vr because i do
remember the first time i tried beat
saber and the first time i tried
superhot i did get that same kind of
feeling that i got playing super mario
64 for the first time which is just like
your brain has never experienced
something like this before and it's just
[ __ ] pure cocaine it was like
like the first time i played super vr
was like it's like one of the funnest
gaming experiences i've ever had yeah
like period absolutely but like that was
that was an hour or so or however long
it took me to play super bowl there's no
big games in vr yeah they're all really
good like one to three hours where's the
next mark where's the mario vr game dude
i want to mario vr game where i am mario
it means that movement is limited
movement yeah you
if you let like mario kart vr was mario
kart v yeah yeah it could be i think
there are racing games in vr well they
did it in uh they did it in mario land
so why can't they do it in oculus that
was not very good though that wasn't
very good but
you know what i mean right like if we
get like a mario kart vr
i think right now the problem is like
movement is really hard yeah and when
movement is realistic it's not good
that's not what you want right but also
if you add unrealistic movement to your
character it becomes really hard to make
it feel real like that i mentioned where
you jump around yeah you don't jump
around you just point the stick and
press jump because you can't do that
movement there's no i can't i can't jump
in my [ __ ] room like an engine right
i wish i could you know
i want to be on the sidelines watching
that yeah i wish i could i will never
get bored of like the random [ __ ] every
like random clips like that sometimes
get recommended on my youtube of like
grandma's trying vr for the first time
and like them doing like the balance
beam game or something just like jumping
head first into a wall jumping and [ __ ]
like a guy jumping into his tv right
that was my favorite
or like the grandma who like oh i think
it was a grandma grandpa who did like
the the climbing one and uh they like
slowly fell
like they fell into like a table or
i something there's some places you can
do it and it's like an activity
they're the vr headsets that the cables
go up to the roof yeah and it's like a
treadmill you're standing yeah yeah yeah
yeah like an omni direction oh yeah
yeah you can have a gun and then you
like run around
i know if there's one place in shinjuku
i think you can do that really yeah with
the treadmills i think yeah i've done
that what the [ __ ] yeah i know there's a
few in america yeah it looks really cool
it looks really really nice really i'd
like to try that out like imagine it's
one where it's like a trampoline that
gives you like feedback based on how
much pressure you put on the trampoline
or something kind of thing yeah because
like i felt like you're in gravity and
the trampoline gets stiffer yeah yeah
and if it's like less you know you're on
like a swamp landing like yeah
like i've heard like one technique that
people use to combat motion sickness in
vr games right is to literally drinking
uh vitamin c
eating a [ __ ] ton of oranges eating a
[ __ ] pouring some salt
in their wounds
but uh also actually just like walking
like walking in the spot you know like
like just literally just literally like
just moving your legs to make it feel
like you're walking and it's just weird
that that just like
that is enough
your brain into thinking oh okay this is
this is real walking now i can
understand this right
i've never done that before i should try
it i should try that i don't know
yeah i mean like it's it's vr right now
is
at the very new stages i'm very
interested to see
how and like if if gaming gets to a
point where this kind of does become
mainstream and we get some like actual
triple a games with vr games because you
have right now
it seems like a very overpriced piece of
tech for a lot of tech demos yeah it's a
shame because i really like it i really
want it to evolve
but i think it's going to be where i i
think it would be really sick and
mainstream for like another 10
years at least i'm just waiting man i
want sword online
i'm i'm going to be jamming in vr when
it's out oh yeah yeah i want to be that
dad that is like in like doing his pc
stuff all the time playing games i'm i'm
gonna be that dad of course of course
we're gonna be the generation when we're
retired we're like oh finally i can get
started with that back catalog of games
right yeah aren't we getting close to
the year that sword art line was set now
as well 2025 i think yeah something like
that i mean it could be done just like i
don't know how i remember just like just
hook a wire up to your like pc or
something that like electrocutes you if
you die in the game
it's like
like you actually just like gives you
like a like a shock
it gives you a lethal voltage if you die
in the game like we could just do we
could probably do it now we just don't
because we're scared of what we could
create well i'm sure this is scared of
advancements in technology 2022 so this
year oh this is actually this online is
this year let's go
i i actually read i think they're
releasing like someone's releasing an
mmo the first vr mmo
oh my god it's real it's real it's real
we can barely make good mmos
now i hope i get selected as a beater
you are a beta